mas ir contra 100 bilhões em mesmo 2 vai
falar é claro disso aqui quem fala é o
dark sejam muito bem vindos a maio 6 e
tem mostrado de que mais um vídeo de um
laser essa medida não só hoje nós vamos
fazer aqui um experimento que na minha
cabeça faz sentir mas não sei se
funciona mesmo e pergunta de hoje é
possível explodir sem balões um único
raio laser e uma fileira de bom explodir
tudo com realeza não é possível sua vez
aqui não é eu próprio nem sair mas eu
acho que consegui então comecei só acho
que vai dar certo assunto não vai
cometer e estou muito ansioso sério mas
não só em quantidade como os que já tem
aqui no meu quarto aí tem muito
movimentado é porque eu tive de estar
experimentou país o lugar de um balão de
comboio boy esconder porque o falcão
objetivo não só eu tenho aqui um saque
bom eu pelo sim pelo não eu comprei 200
balões pretos como vocês sabem o preto é
o que atrai melhor os dois então é mais
fácil implementar de 81 segundo a lei
pode só vai 321 é sobre cada um foi
instantâneo construir um sistema para
colocar todos bons em fila ou vejam só
em tese é muito louco eu sou muito em
cima da zaga pra isso
basicamente o kula um balão aqui no
fundo do copo com um conselho verdade
que depois é só colocar outro copo por
baixo com água e isso vai fazer peso
assim não caem em cima uns dos outros né
eu vou tentar colocar 100 deste bolo em
segunda fila gigante e eu só vou ligar o
laser e vamos ver o que acontecerá com o
esporro em tudo ao mesmo tempo único
hayman o kangoo jump logo a seguir a
outro tempo não sair não faz idéia é
portanto vamos testar esse movimento que
eu vou fazer lá fora é onde eu tenho
mais paz tem um jardim mas eu não sei se
vou conseguir usar rearmamento samba
longe então vou tentar usar o máximo de
golos que o conseguiu e vejam só a
história não só aqui no chão olha como é
que está o leite tem muito bom aqui eu
sei que parece pouco mas tenho muito
ainda tem mais lá embaixo diz tem um
mecanismo já construído tipo que muito
tempo construir isso antes fazer um
vídeo e eu vou fazer isso e porque eu
sugeri isso não vire passado lá e que
gosta de comentar muito por fazer
então eu vou fazer lá
pois é é porque o seu bem curioso também
e eu não sei que vai na comunidade o que
vocês acham que vai dar disse ter ouvido
isso é muito importante porque assim
saiba a opinião já fica nos comentários
e posso te responder eu acho que vou
fazer isso japão e já só não só deixe
muito líquido e os filhos muito
importante canal para cristina imenso e
tudo graças a vocês só posso marcar
nossas partidas nossos comentários tudo
isso então muito obrigado e forem novos
e que no final só que estaremos também
com toda a força e muita força aqui no
bar só opções primeiras em que mora lá
então fazer que este texto muito ansioso
e 8 muito ansioso porque é muito balão e
agora processo que vou ter que fazer um
processo bem chato eu acho que nem vou
filmar em vídeo eu vou ter que mandar
bom estúdio lei para jardim eu vou ter
que colocar em fila e depois ainda
voltei por água nos corpos de presos
ficarem se estava até pouco importante
eles não estarem completamente parado de
stapp porque se um raio mas enquanto
estava a ter um jato car no outro por
cuba vai passar o rolo muito rápido
então quanto mais tempo estivermos
melhor
rio - e eu acho isso cientistas por
cento excluindo a tua lógica de cara do
cientista networking a lei cara do
cientista
assim você não duvido nada que mude não
é só tentar sua língua agora é possível
excluir 100 bilhões com um único raio
laser será foram então eu vou mandar
obama provasse agora e vamos lá embora
vão embora no ano
eu amo só aqui em baixo e agora vou
receber o primeiro bolão sua filha de
bundões vai ficar daquela ponto da china
é esta planta aqui então vai ser muito
bom mesmo resultado leva a equipe apan
não pode sair da banda é nenê construir
mas eu só comecei a ficar só um filme
muito grande eu não sei quanto não estou
aqui
messi está muito bom já olha só eu tô
sabendo que estão linha a linha de
referência europeus ficarem bem reto
muitas eo pioneirismo não é que está na
luz boa noite tenho que encher com água
da piscina e ir lá colocar à frente
muito cansado mas vai valer apenas a
racco projetar quase feito só falta um
pouco de mamãe já está quase a chegar
até a preta eu não sei se vocês e mãe só
mas o nosso desafio quanto em quanto não
estou aqui comentei eu acho que pagar
aproximadamente uns
sinto nojo não sair e eu só não faço
aqui no relvado tem muita mais distância
mas eu só faço aqui porque estamos bons
vão cair ainda mais nossa senhora mãe aí
e é só mas o que está a acontecer agora
é o vento está a ficar mais forte está
tudo que eu preciso fazer isso muito
rápido e colocar mais água quero muito
que dê certo se eles têm que dar certo
também que o curioso nome disso é eu ter
muito trabalho com em francês não
voltava tem muito dependente ano
ai eu não sou mais de seu último falou
de mauá 32 nem foi lá está o último
último escolhido na nota que não vai
reinventar a aposta vai superar isso e
vamos salvar nossa fileira do não está
pronta está completamente cheia que o
chão vejam só conectar olha aí é muito
longa
[Música]
bom pessoal deu muito trabalho mas estou
aqui aproximadamente 70 bilhões mas
quando e como enquanto estão aqui
exatamente porque eu não contei agora
sim só vai ser um momento da verdade nós
vamos testar o nosso lado e espero
crescer ser eu espero muito porque tem
muito trabalho tanto proporção dos
balões como ir buscar o material e os
corpos foram muitos copos encher com
água mandar tudo acima cá para baixo de
muito trabalho mesmo portanto eu espero
que isso tudo fica lá no banheiro no
teste e sujeito dólar é e não só por
isso dar certo vou ter que fazer duas
coisas uma delas é visto os bancos estão
completamente alinhados em linha reta e
outra em aruba execuções qualquer pessoa
o que vocês acham assunto é alinhado
este aqui está um pouco torto mas um
blazer vai pegar eu acho que há certa
portanto eu acho tudo né
só lá em cima que eu acho que não muda é
que além das imagens conta no twitter o
bullying melhor forma de visitar minha
mãe e agora pessoal pra mim era o nosso
acervo será que esta ferramenta qual eu
vou botar o laser assim eu acho que eu
não abro até o máximo até agora é só
fechar aqui ó banho nas ruas a qualquer
dos alunos foi executar muito é
importado e agora é só encaixar este
ferro ali no fundo ela só até pessoal eu
achei um baldaquino mg bem nojento da
chinesa por dentro e vou tentar usar
isto eu não sei se vai dar certo mas de
nada porque acho que sim vai tão bem
assim eu estava em cima de uma coisa
mais baixa que em 2010 pensando nisso
mais frio e só eu final não vou usar o
qual eu direi que um balão já agora vou
aguentar o balão em 321 vai só vamos lá
fazer o cálculo do novo player
basicamente o nosso lazer vai ter que
mantê la no paredão mas lá ver se eu
consigo precisa aportar aqui ok agora só
quero mais é que ela não só para salvar
se instalar na parede e agora que eu
precisei desviá-lo provado mas tal e até
agora é a hora de provar agora é agora
eu acho que vai juntar o que você
colocar outra câmera gravar aqui pra
vocês têm mais ângulos de visão já vem
já vou chamá lo
a roupa e bora lá pessoal disse já deixa
o vosso mega liquidez pires ainda não
deixaram a ser é muito importante mesmo
este experimento apesar de ser simples
foi muito complicado fazer né provou
muito tempo construir então é isso só o
muricy posso falar que eu acho que vamos
responder à nossa pergunta é possível
explodir sem balões com raio laser foram
lá fazer compras em bonn em 32 ufu vai
ainda a perder força e já perdeu força
aqui não pode sê-lo e sete golos foi bom
mas não é isso que eu quero vou
aproximaram mas afirmou que muito embora
lá eles não vai só daqui a um tempo
tenta não é possível só não é possível
meu grande por lá que as mães agora 31
vai ai ó eu crio sá
conseguimos levantar todos os balões não
de um raio apenas né mas não funcionou
como eu estava eu estava com a
documentação em todos mas o
empreendimento vai ser não é assim tão
potente para aguentar sem mãe então só
minuto 17 bom negócio é bom eu penso não
só sujeira que ficou aqui olha aí dona
piscina e só agora pessoa nós
respondemos à nossa pergunta é possível
aguentar sem balões com um único raio
laser talvez seja mas com um laser mais
potente já está a caminho dos jornais de
10 cápsulas a encomenda seria muito mais
potente e talvez se dê conta do recado
nesta que só conseguiu aguentar tudo
certo eu agora vou aproveitar os corpos
que eu tenho aqui vamos tentar fazer uma
torre de 200 copos para tentar fazer
isso mais rápido que o ciro mais rápido
muito rápido só vai embora mas o jogo
foi muito claro falhas ou o equilíbrio
só com os dedos bem como espera só com
the wall
como é que eu consegui isso é possível
mas nasci jica
olha isso não é só a química física
também é irmão do meio ponto
calma calma calma ofereço só está muito
pesado e quadros conquistou 32 um vai e
olha só meus uma equilibrista presa numa
rua ou o sol equilibrar os copos
então é isso só vamos ficar com estrelas
para fazer tenham estado apesar do
experimento não ter dado certo e
diverti-me imenso prazer também tenhamos
tap já sabem deixei muito claro que
neste vídeo para eu continuar a fazer
esta experiência e isso não foi inscrito
e no canal só escrevo muito em baixo
exigindo muito canal e aqui em cima
vocês vão poder ver 2000 e tenho certeza
que vão divertir e aqui em baixo
novamente vocês vão poder subscrever
aqui no canal da arc e da hora itens
pessoal fiquem bem até aproximando